الطبيه وبالتالي نقوم بالتوجيه الطائرات
وتوجيه الرحلات والتوجيه كل المساعدات
بشكل
يناسب الاولويات والحاجات الاولويه طبعا
كان
رئيس وزراء باكستانيا اود ان يزور
تركيا ولكن لان الرئيس التركي الان يزور
المناطق المنكوبه وبالتالي
اضطررنا الى تاجيل زياره
رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه ايضا وزير
الخارجيه الاذربيجاني السيد جيهون كان
يعود ان يزور تركيا وبالتالي نحن ايضا
نركز على تحديد المواعيد
للوقت المناسب لاجراء زين نحن الان نقوم
بواجبنا يعني انا الان
اجيب على سؤالك لانك سالتني ولكن كل هذه
الامور هي واجب وزاره الخارجي واجبنا
جميعا كبشر
لانه لدينا
هذه الامكانيات وعلينا ان
نكرسها في المكان الصحيح علينا ان نعمل في
المكان الصحي بشكل صحيح نحن
نقدم كل الدعم اللازم
لتاهيل هذه المناطق لايواء المتضررين من
الزلازل وايضا نحاول على اجراء المناطق
اجلاء المواطنين الذين يتواجدون في هذا
المنطق الذين يودون الذين يودون الخروج من
هذه المناطق والانتقال من هنا الى المدن
الامنه وبالتالي نعمل على تامين هذه
المناطق ووضع المخيمات ونصب المخيمات
ومراكز الايواء المؤقته وايضا اجلاء
المواطنين من هناك
هناك بعض المواطنين الذين يتركون هذه
المدن يخرجون منها بامكانياتهم وبامكانتهم
الخاصه وايضا هناك بعض المعتل الذين
يحتاجون دعمنا للخروج من هذه
المدن هناك بعض المدن التي افتتحت فنادقها
وتستقبل
المواطنين الذين
تضرروا من الزلازل ايضا في مدن انطاليا
والمانيا يفتتحون الفنادق كما تعلمون هناك
بعض الفنادق التي تغلق في الشتاء
ولكنها افتتحت هذه الفنادق مبانيها وقمت
بكل الاستعدادات اللازمه من